well
[Music]
there have been new leaks in the
fight against the coronavirus in southern
nevada this Sunday
1,900 new cases were reported and eight deaths is an
average less than what has been
recorded in the last two weeks and
it is worth mentioning that  Fewer tests were carried
out during these holidays,
so there could be an increase in
cases in the coming weeks and many
will already begin to get rid of their
Christmas trees, so
the public is reminded that there are
free services to recycle their
resident trees.  leave your tree
undecorated until January 15 at at
least 30 sites around the valley if
your tree is over 5 feet tall they
are asked to cut it in half
plus trees with fake snow will not
be accepted last year were
recycled  almost 17,000 trees so
if you are looking to receive
yours recycle visit and news.com and then tel serca
celebrates its grand opening tonight the
tower  of rooms officially opens
today just in time for the end of the year and
has 60
making it the tallest building
in the hotel zone on the north side of
el street the rooms were
decorated with classic elements of las
vegas' the fence is the first
casino hotel exclusively for adults
throughout the city and will also host
the countdown to the new year
2021 we will wait for you on our
digital platforms and the
home team the riders ended their season
at the li jong stadium with a defeat
against the dolphins of  miami on saturday and
so they also lost their last
chance to play in the
semifinals in an intense game the
raiders lost by one point against
the dolphins and now they will end the
season facing the
denver broncos next sunday and the clouds
and rain come to the  las vegas valley'
it is anticipated that at least one
tenth inch of water will accumulate in our region
the national service d  The weather
has also predicted a small chance
of snowfall for the west and
northwest areas of the city High
temperatures in the valley will remain
in the 50s so it will be cloudy for today
Monday while tomorrow Tuesday and
Wednesday it is expected to be sunny and
the clouds return  for
Wednesday night as well as the winds for
the night of the new year so it
has not been determined if they will cancel the
fireworks for now they are still on
happy new year we are here at news now
dotcom to serve you
[Music]